do you ever wish that you could shop in
your friend's closet hundreds of
thousands of women Brian are doing just
that on Poshmark and they're buying and
selling new and second-hand Fashion Home
Goods as well as Electronics so we take
a look at the latest trends that will
get you the most cash and some tips from
a Summerlin Savvy seller
a clean freak if you can't tell so using
this app to just kind of declutter is
key for me 34 year old Alexa caracostis
wanted to purge her closet of some old
purses initially she thought garage sale
and my friend was like these items are
way too high value and you know for a
garage sale you should try Poshmark
she set up a Poshmark account featuring
a Gucci purse she bought back in 2011. I
was like it's so out of style within
minutes that old purse ended up being a
fashion find selling for 800 bucks
looking back I probably could have sold
it for more Poshmark is a go-to
destination for Shoppers to pick up
brand name items at an affordable price
features brand new and pre-loved items
but Alexa warns be prepared to put in
the work the site is great like very
easy to navigate but it is tedious with
managing inquiry shipping labels having
the right size packaging she adds it's
also important to curate your Poshmark
page just like any other social media
page people want to see pretty pictures
she adds fresh flowers in the background
to create a nice setting to display her
items and she says it's all worth it she
made nearly two thousand dollars her
first month with the sale of the Gucci
bag and small jewelry back in the early
2000s everyone was wearing those Tiffany
like dog tag necklaces it was like a
chain and it said you know return to tip
I had that sitting in my jewelry box for
17 years that was a huge Trend like
people are looking for vintage Tiffany
vintage Gucci really vintage anything
Alexa appreciates the business a little
thank you for your order card so I
always sign the back of these and
ability to cash in on something that
otherwise would have been clutter in her
closet one man's trash is another man's
treasure
indeed well here's the bad news Poshmark
charges sellers fees and commissions
it's a flat rate of 295 for anything
under 15 bucks 20 above for items above
other sites like mercari thredup tradesy
and the real real vintage and eBay some
other sites that don't cost as much